bienvenidos de nuevo al final del vídeo
anterior les dejé con una pregunta
teníamos el caso donde había un objeto
de un kilogramo digamos que aquí está
nuestro objeto que era como una especie
de caja y tenía una masa de un kilogramo
y digamos que estamos en la tierra
verdad porque si estuviéramos en otro
planeta la aceleración es diferente
entonces cada cada aceleración o cada
efecto de aceleración debido a la
gravedad es distinto en cada planeta así
que vamos a suponer que estamos en la
tierra y en ese caso digamos que estamos
sosteniendo esta caja de un kilogramo de
masa y la sostenemos como a 10 metros de
altura entonces digamos que esta caja
está a 10 metros de altura del suelo
y más o menos estamos aquí midiendo 10
metros de altura muy bien entonces estos
son 10 metros 10 metros muy bien
entonces además vamos a suponer para
fines de que sea más fácil todas las
operaciones que hagamos que la
aceleración debida a la gravedad es de
10 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado ok
ya sabemos que en realidad para cuando
estamos en la tierra es de 9.81 metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado pero para que
sean más fáciles las cuentas y las
operaciones vamos a suponer que es de 10
metros sobre el segundo al cuadrado muy
bien entonces lo que vimos en el vídeo
antes en el vídeo anterior y era
estábamos hablando de la conservación de
la energía verdad de hecho empezamos
viendo que la energía potencial que
tiene este objeto a esta altura
simplemente se calculaba como la masa
por la por la aceleración debido a la
gravedad por la altura que en este caso
es la masa es de un kilogramo
tendríamos un kilogramo que multiplica a
la gravedad que son 10 metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado y
multiplicamos por la altura que es de 10
metros 10 metros y entonces qué es lo
que obtenemos simplemente obtenemos que
esto es 1 por 10 por 10 son 100
'tenemos kilogramos metros sobre segundo
al cuadrado eso son newtons y nos quedan
unos metros así que newtons por metros
ya habíamos dicho que eran jules que es
la unidad en la que medimos la energía
muy bien entonces si este objeto está a
esta altura sabemos que tiene una
energía de 100 jules que ésta está
pensada como en su forma potencial
verdad esto es energía potencial ahora
bien si nosotros digamos que aquí estoy
pintando el pasto verdad que este es el
suelo
digamos que este es el suelo y si
nosotros dejamos caer este objeto de un
kilogramo nosotros queremos saber cuánto
es una energía potencial verdad la
energía potencial si estamos en este
punto digamos si si dejamos caer la caja
en ese punto cuál sería pues tendríamos
su masa que es de un kilogramo la
gravedad o la aceleración debido a la
gravedad que es de 10 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado pero la altura es
cero así que la energía potencial es
cero en ese momento muy bien entonces
hablábamos de la conservación de la
energía pero si aquí tenemos que la
energía potencial vale cero entonces qué
pasó con estos cien jules que teníamos
inicialmente pues lo que ocurre es que
estos cien jules se hicieron energía
cinética ok entonces la energía cinética
uno podría recordar las fórmulas de la
energía cinética de hecho es conveniente
verdad si no te acuerdas debería
revisarlo en los vídeos anteriores que
hemos estado trabajando
energía y trabajo justamente y no es no
es malo repasar esos vídeos de hecho es
bueno porque a veces ese tipo de
fórmulas es difícil memorizar las pero
es es bueno tenerlas muy muy presentes
en la mente así que sí toda esta energía
ahora es energía cinética uno podría
calcular cuál es su velocidad verdad
porque si teníamos esencialmente que
toda esta energía potencial toda esta
energía potencial ahora se hizo energía
cinética
digamos está ahora todo se convirtió en
energía cinética si recordamos la
fórmula de la energía cinética esto es
un medio por la masa por la velocidad al
cuadrado cual velocidad pues justo la
velocidad que lleva esta caja en este
preciso momento en el que cae al suelo
ok justo antes en el momento más
inmediato antes de caer al suelo tiene
esa velocidad verdad entonces qué es lo
que vamos a tener que estos 100 jules
que teníamos de energía potencial se van
a convertir ahora en 100 jules pero de
energía cinética entonces tendremos que
si esta es la energía cinética vamos a
tener que un medio por la masa que es un
kilogramo de hecho déjenme ponerlo con
el mismo color un medio por un kilogramo
por la velocidad al cuadrado
vamos a dejarlo como así por la
velocidad al cuadrado deben ser 100
jules muy bien entonces si pasa si
multiplicamos de ambos lados por 2 y
bueno un kilogramo pues pues no no nos
afecta mucho tendremos que la velocidad
al cuadrado son exactamente 200 verdad
son 200 y si la velocidad al cuadrado
son 200 quiere decir que la velocidad
tiene que ser quien quien tiene que ser
la velocidad pues sacamos la raíz
cuadrada de 200 verdad entonces tenemos
200 y sacamos su raíz cuadrada y son
14.1 vamos a dejarlo así estos son 14.1
metros sobre segundo y aquí no he hecho
bien el análisis de las de las unidades
verdad aquí tengo kilogramos dedican
celular lo saca pero bueno tú en el
examen hazlo con mucho cuidado aquí sólo
es para fines prácticos muy bien
entonces justo en el momento en el
preciso momento en el que toque
no antes sino después en ese preciso
momento vamos a tener que lleva a una
velocidad de 14.1 metros sobre segundo
ahora bien en realidad esto lo pudimos
calcular a lo mejor con cinemática pero
pero pero en realidad es un es un
problema difícil cuál sería entonces el
punto de la energía si tenemos una
fórmula cinemática vamos a ver por qué
es útil esto
vamos a ver no sé vamos a quitar todo
esto vamos a quitar todo esto muy bien
no sé
vamos a quitar
muy bien sólo hay que recordar todas y
todo lo que teníamos de energía cinética
que justo fue lo que borré
ahora lo pongo
ahí está estos serán 100 jules muy bien
ahora supongamos que tenemos esta misma
caja pero ahora se encuentra sobre una
rampa que es de hielo bien entonces
digamos que tenemos nuestra rama pista
de hielo bueno eso no es una ramita en
realidad es una rampa muy grande y
pronunciada y no es uniforme digamos no
es como como un plano inclinado sino
puede ser cualquier cosa entonces
y nosotros queremos no ser digamos
supongamos que tenemos estos mismos diez
metros de altura hoy vamos a cambiar la
línea tenemos estos diez metros de
altura ok esto mide diez metros de
altura y entonces al soltar la caja y
tomamos una rampa de hielo justamente
para pensar que la fricción es
despreciable entonces empieza a recorrer
este este camino hasta llegar al extremo
en donde ya va de forma horizontal muy
bien entonces usando las fórmulas de la
cinemática puede ser muy difícil o muy
complicado saber cuál es la velocidad
que lleva esta caja en cada momento de
entrada pues necesitaríamos saber
cálculo diferencial integral para pues
pues la pendiente de esta curva que
representa nuestra rampa está cambiando
de forma continua a medida que este que
esta caja va avanzando así que a lo
mejor tendríamos no sé qué descomponer
en vectores
no sé habría que hacer varias cosas
matemáticas que podrían resultar muy
complicados pero utilizando la misma
idea de la energía de la conservación de
la energía este problema se vuelve muy
fácil ok y eso porque es esencialmente
es porque si teníamos que al inicio 100
jules teníamos 100 jules en su forma
potencial es decir como energía
potencial entonces la energía cinética
en este momento si la altura ya es cero
tendremos nuevamente el caso que la
energía cinética es de 100 es verdad si
si la altura es 0 no tenemos energía
potencial y toda esa energía potencial
debió convertirse entonces en energía
cinética que son esos mismos 100 jules
ahora esto es igual a un medio por la
masa por la velocidad al cuadrado y
esencialmente es el mismo problema que
teníamos anteriormente entonces la
velocidad sería de 14.1 metros sobre
segundo
esa es la velocidad que llevaría y por
supuesto hay que decir en qué dirección
en este caso no iría hacia abajo sino
hacia la derecha que es hacia dónde se
mueve nuestra caja ahora bien que qué
más puede hacer la energía por mí digo
aquí me resuelve el problema de la misma
forma y pues ahora no importo realmente
la figura de la rampa entonces qué más
puede hacer por mí si de la otra forma
se resuelve también entonces lo que yo
creo que es fascinante de la ley de la
conservación de la energía es que
podemos en realidad calcular la
velocidad en cualquier punto por ejemplo
si tuviéramos aquí una altura de cinco
metros digamos aquí una altura de cinco
metros y que nuestra caja ahora se
encuentre aquí de un kilogramo entonces
lo que sabemos es que la energía
potencial final
en realidad la energía se conserva
verdad entonces la energía potencial que
teníamos al inicio
la energía cinética que teníamos al
inicio debe ser igual a la energía
potencial que tenemos al final más la
energía potencial perdón la energía
cinética que tenemos al final muy bien
entonces inicialmente nosotros teníamos
100 jules 100 giles
y no teníamos energía cinética dado que
su velocidad inicial era cero estaba en
el reposo ahora bien esto debería ser
igual a la energía potencial final que
en nuestro caso son cinco metros de
altura verdad aquí tendríamos cinco
metros por la gran por la aceleración de
la gravedad que son diez por la masa que
es 1 entonces aquí tenemos 50 jules e
insisto que hagas muy muy detalladamente
el análisis de las dimensiones más una
energía cinética que vamos a dejarlo así
pues porque no es exactamente final pero
en este momento debe ser la energía
cinética más 50 nos deben dar 100 jules
esto quiere decir que la energía
cinética en este caso son 50 jules 50
jules ahora bien si la energía cinética
son 50 jules entonces tendremos que 50
debe ser igual a un medio por la masa
por la velocidad al cuadrado entonces
la masa es 1 así que 100 debe ser la
velocidad al cuadrado y por lo tanto la
velocidad debe ser 10 metros sobre
segundo por supuesto en la dirección que
lleve en ese momento de sobre la rampa
verdad y entonces sería casi imposible
resolver este problema solo con fórmulas
cinemáticas ni siquiera tenemos una
ecuación para describir la rampa está
loca que hicimos así que es más difícil
que si utilizamos la ley de la
conservación de la energía y viendo que
la mitad de la energía potencial es
ahora energía cinética verdad justo lo
que hicimos aquí
entonces de esta forma pudimos calcular
la velocidad
en la dirección de la resbaladilla nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo